première fois ensemble le processus
d'immigration n'est pas évident en temps
normal il est encore moins en temps de
pandémie 9,6 allemagne ont reçu nos
papiers puis on verra aussi le 16 avril
2009 plus de 15 mois se sont écoulés
depuis que le couple marié a fait une
demande de résidence permanente pour
anna les délais sont habituellement de
12 mois
malgré des appels répétés impossible
d'en savoir plus sur l'évolution de leur
dossier pendant ce temps la brésilienne
ne peut pas travailler ni conduire elle
ne veut pas non plus retourner dans son
pays par peur de ne pas être autorisé à
revenir
c'est vraiment lourd et difficile pour
notre relation parce que je suis séparé
de ma famille elle déjà difficile après
un nouveau l'un est rentré un nouveau
pays et je fais de tout pour ma rentrée
grèce est entré y est intégré c'est
impossible non plus de fonder une
famille et avec le pôle assurance
publique à coucher tout c est normal
frais chercher l'internet quand les pros
mérite est d'avoir les enfants après les
quarante ans sur son site internet le
ministère de l'immigration écrit qu'en
raison des répercussions de lakovic 19
nous ne pouvons pas traiter les demandes
normalement il fournir des délais de
traitement exact il ajoute que la
priorité est accordée aux demandes des
canadiens qui essaient de revenir au
canada les personnes vulnérables et des
personnes qui fournissent un appui des
services essentiels
nous sommes dans le noir on sait pas
comment les dossiers sont traités sont
tous les dossiers de papier ils ont dit
qu'ils continuent à être at-elle de
cinéma mais pas les dossiers des papiers
mais nous sommes obligés de les mêler
les marchés un an et jonathan ne sont
d'ailleurs pas les seuls dans cette
situation
plus de 2500 personnes qui vivent une
réalité similaire font partie d'un
groupe facebook leur député joël heit
bonne reconnaît par courriel que la
pandémie a fait augmenter les délais de
traitement de certains dossiers
d'immigration
le couple demande donc que les dossiers
qui excède les douze mois d'attentes
soient traitées en priorité
ça donne l'impression qu'on est un
numéro pickeu alors que déjà des impacts
psychologiques
le stress c
la perte d'espoir derrière chaque
demande
il y à des humains qui attendent
impatiemment
si marie pierre mercier radio canada
québec